orphan black it's a mixture of so many
kind of genres because it's sort of
detective work there's action there's
sci-fi supernatural is it a challenge
for you and the rest of the cast to get
it all grounded in reality the mixture
of all the genres in orphan black i
think is done masterfully by our writers
so
once again uh
it's easy to ground it in reality
because
nothing is is
is out of the possibility of reality in
our show everything exists in that realm
so we're not like like i said we're not
doing you know it's we're not doing
things that can't be done
so therefore it you know it is easy and
for our our actress our lead actress
she's you know she's the one that's
doing all the heavy lifting you know
we're playing a single character and
she's playing multiple so that's
probably the part that's uh
that you know she's the one that that
keeps us grounded in reality because if
she didn't do such a masterful job our
if we had a you know second-rate actress
doing this work our show would be
rubbage so you know she's doing a great
job so she makes it easy for all of us
as the show's progressed it's to your
character's gone into darker territories
and there's more ambiguity throughout i
suppose i mean i mean do you um how do
you approach the challenge of
getting into some sort of morally
questionable territory um
my character has definitely gone darker
as the show's progressed um the
challenge is is is
it's very simple actually because for
some reason when i when i used to
audition uh in los angeles quite often
everybody would say there's an you're a
very nice guy but there's an inherent
darkness to you so i guess my mom called
me after watching the recent most recent
episode because i would tell my mother
that i was like i went for this this you
know this role and she was supposed to
be this nice lawyer and they said there
was an inherent darkness to my read so
my mom goes
i could never understand why they would
say that and then she goes i saw that
last episode she goes and now i
understand why they're saying there's
that inherent darkness but you know it's
you know it's just fun just to go dark
with this character because he's kind of
a badass and i've been waiting you know
to unleash the bad acid-ness so if you
um so yeah no it wasn't that hard and
also it's you know all the actors on our
show are so great so it's easy to react
off them because they're really emoting
you know
the proper emotions in every scene and
then everybody's going 100 and everybody
is is really good so it's just it's easy
to go dark and it's easy to react off
that in certain situations within the
scene
people do seem to respond as well i mean
interesting you mentioned the badass
element because i'm well i mean as i've
noticed here that not only you've been
referred to as hot pool but uh e online
recently named you the best ass on prime
time
they certainly did yeah how does that
feel um being named the best ass on
primetime well now my girlfriend grabs
my my rear end a lot more she's very
proud of it um
in my my hotel room in london there was
actually a mural of a man's ass in my
room so i don't know if that was a
practical joke by the the lovely people
at london comic con or was that really
the artwork for my room it's very
flattering you know i do a lot of squats
in the off season and i work out very
hard so to beat out all those guys on
trueblood um you know because those guys
show bear bear all quite often i was uh
i was very uh very honored to be
bestowed to be bestowed that that title
um no it's uh you know the hot paul
moniker that name is makes me very
uncomfortable because like i said i was
probably 130 pounds in high school with
braces on so i've i think i've come a
long way so um i usually i'm a very i
sweat a lot so i thought they were
referring to my sweating tendencies when
they said hot paul but i guess that's
not it um but yeah no it makes me
extremely uncomfortable as you can see
right now
well i want to refer to it again that's
all right that's all right now you could
call me that well just call me call me
luke warren today i'm very i'm very
yes tepid paul i'm very
jet-lagged so you can call me lukewarm
bags under the eyes yeah
which actor would you love to have in an
episode of orphan black which actor
would i love to have in an episode
since i'm in london i would uh and i
know he would probably never do
television i would say tom hardy i think
tom hardy uh would be a
you know a magnificent force to uh to
have on set and i'm a big fan of tom
hardy so i think that would be a
very very fun actor to have on orphan
black do you have a favorite sci-fi film
uh favorite sci-fi film uh probably
would be
2001 space odyssey i think i love that
film i i it's uh
it's it's so creepy and amazing yeah
it's a classic yeah you could clone
anyone from the past to bring back to
life
to meet hang out with whatever right who
would it be probably be my my
grandfather i never met him he was uh
they had my mother when they were very
old he was born in uh
1897 and he fought in world war one when
he was when he was young and
that would probably be the person that i
would love to meet because he was
apparently a very stand-up gentleman so
i would love to meet him